you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
george camel with a k
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two five george and i are here for
you today together and so uh you know
this show if you've been listening for
any amount of time but if you're new to
the show
we really are helping you in those three
major areas relationships your
professional work life and your
financial life they are all
interconnected and so george and i are
here for you uh listen if you've got a
really sticky situation
and you feel like you need someone to
help you today but it's it's private in
nature uh kelly is standing by
she'll change your name your location i
just want to reach out to you and say
hey come on we'll protect your identity
because we want to help you get that
breakthrough that you need you ready to
go can kelly change my name while we're
at it
kelly can do a lot of things very
powerful wouldn't put a pastor i would
not i would not let's start with
sebastian who joins us in the city of
angels los angeles sebastian how can we
help
hi
i totally did not expect to be on the
phone i just called randomly well great
i thought he called the wrong number for
a second did you want to order a pizza
or did you want to talk to us because we
can help you with both
oh man so
um i'm 21 years old um and i actually
just uh sold my car i got it with equity
actually i sold my 2014 mustang those
gas prices were killing me that car was
just sitting down
so right now i'm saving myself about
like 700 bucks a month now because of it
nice and like it was just sitting there
so my question to you is i made that
mistake twice i bought two cars of those
sold them i probably lost about like
eight nine thousand dollars in those
cars but oh well they were fun
um
i have uh i'm an emt at the moment
emergency medical technician i work for
minimum wage and i don't want to be here
forever so i want to appreciate nursing
actually nursing school
so at the moment i am wondering whether
i should take my time with it i can go
full time if i want to finish all the
prerequisites i need to
but the problem is i can get i can get
wait listed for like three four years
and might not even ever get in now
there's another option it's called west
coast university and i can
get into student loan it's like a
hundred and forty thousand dollars
no
no it's not a good idea stop no
you don't need to go into debt
for a hundred and forty thousand dollars
to be a nurse and i'm gonna tell you why
there's a lot better ways to do it we'll
break that down in a second but let me
just lead with the bumper sticker
sebastian
any love or passion and purpose you
would have for nursing
will quickly dissipate
within months of watching that massive
student loan
debt
come in the mail it's just gonna kill
all joy for loving on people do you
understand what i'm saying
i do it's worth waiting for
it's worth waiting for
what are your options to to do this
what are your options to do this without
taking out debt
i i don't have to that's the thing but i
don't know i think i'm just more like
like i want to help people but i also
want to be making
the money i get it you just ignored
everything i said sebastian
your response was but
i want to be making more money and you
think making more money as an rn is
gonna is gonna be the better trade-off
what you're not hearing is george give
him an idea what those debt payments
what that's going to look like and feel
like emotionally walking through that
sebastian what do you think you'll make
your first year as a nurse
i heard they're making average in
california i'm pretty sure they start
like maybe 70 80 000. that's correct in
three days okay yeah oh yeah 70 80 000.
so that's 70 grand after all the taxes
are taken out and you live in california
so there's a lot of them you're going to
be left with a much smaller take-home
pay and then out of that you're going to
be sending a huge chunk of that probably
30 40
over to sallie mae to pay off the
student loans that you thought were a
good idea and then like ken's saying
you're going to be miserable because
you're going to be stressed out about
the payments every day you come into
work going how am i gonna even put food
on the table this week how am i gonna
live my life and do the things that i
wanna do
man this was a bad idea so i can see
that future for you and we don't want
that we know there's other ways you can
do this we know there's much more
affordable alternatives we know that you
can extend your timeline and cash flow
the experience so that you can graduate
without debt and actually enjoy the work
you do yeah sebastian did you did you
get the math that george just laid out
for you how much of that 70 80 thousand
are you actually going to be able to
live on
not much
all right now listen so so george just
gave you the financial breakdown i want
to come back to the emotional
thing that i led with
because if you do what george says and
you do it and you know how to do it you
do it debt free there are going to be
some long
days as a nurse true or false sebastian
they're going to be some heavy days too
the stuff that you will see am i right
sebastian
yes definitely if you're
working on the ambulance i know
so sebastian
if you're debt free
you're going to be able to withstand
and press through those hard long heavy
days but if you're not debt free
in the midst of all that weight from the
work
you will walk out
like a zombie
going why am i doing this
and then you're going to call the ken
coleman show because i get these calls
ken i'm burned out
i'm trying to stop it
i know but sebastian i'm trying to stop
you from that you're on the front end of
this deal
you can make a little bit more money
why not go get a second job you're 21.
if you want to supplement your income go
do that man
but
stay debt-free in the pursuit of being a
nurse i beg you to stay debt-free
can you do it
i can do it i know you here's your
homework sebastian go find the most
affordable option yes to go to nursing
school then let's do math and go okay
what's this going to take for me to be
able to cash flow this what scholarships
can i go apply for like it's a part-time
job how much can i work on the side to
begin to save up for this or even work
while i'm in school then you develop a
game plan and when you take debt off the
table you're going to get creative and
you're going to start going all right
here's my game plan here's how i'm going
to do this i could save 10 20 000 a year
and i can cash flow this thing in two
years good let's do that
that's right you got it young man you
got your marching orders george gave you
good homework be a good student
do what uncle george said and if you
want to put the fear of god in you
please go watch the borrowed future
documentary that we released
goodness gracious there's no human being
that can watch that documentary and walk
away going i think student loans are all
right uh you'll get a good job at the
end of it life will be okay
no
the horror stories and they're not
cherry-picked this is happening all over
the country
people are really struggling and have a
lot of empathy for those that are
struggling with student loan debt they
feel like they got conned
and the truth is if you keep waiting on
the next president to fix your problems
and get you out of debt you're going to
be waiting a very long time
and so you've got to own up to the thing
that you signed up for the student loan
the interest rate you didn't look at
it's on you and the good news is you're
the solution too
folks listen to me i'm the guy at ramsey
solutions it talks about
making more money and experiencing more
meaning and you can but listen to me if
you if you find that dream job
and you're
in a
horrible horrible pit of debt that will
weigh on you and all of the dream and
all of the love and all the passion
won't matter
take it from me on this
don't go into debt for your future this
is
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help
go to their site
churchillmortgage.com ramsey to start
your approval or get more information
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
nashville hq i'm ken coleman joined by
my colleague ramsey personality george
campbell with a k i i think it's going
to stick it's helpful i think people are
learning slowly i do i want people to
know about you because you're an awesome
dude you're doing great work i
appreciate it and uh it's been fun uh
doing lots of shows with you recently
yeah second or third one this week yeah
yeah yeah we're gonna bring you the
practicality that people long for but
we're gonna have a little fun while we
do it that's not illegal
no not fun while you work george and i
like to have fun by the way he sits
right next to me
so uh your desk is is three you're three
feet away and now we just moved about 20
feet over from our desks to the street
we continue to sit next to each other
it's it's that's what we call a double
blessing that's what we call the
proximity principle that's fair oh boy
the the unnecessary book promotion just
circles in there all right let's get to
the phones it is a free call triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two 825-5225 let's go
to indianapolis
indiana where ray is joining us ray how
can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
bet what's up
so
um they had a interesting last six
months
you know lost a couple jobs over the
last two years and uh
just due to profit
and uh now i'm working in a place um
working in a factory
and in the last six months they're now
promoting me uh which is great
um but i also just had a interview
recently and might get offered a job in
marketing which is why i left
um
the problem i'm having is marketing
would pay more but where i'm at is
probably a lot more stable
so i guess my question is are my fears
justified in wanting something that's
purely stable
or should i take a leap on something
that's going to be
a little bit more pay why is
the current job
or the one the the other job let's call
it the non-marketing job why is that
more stable in your mind
um bigger company much you know it's a
it's a bigger factory there is room to
grow and uh places that you know i could
go the other jobs i did get here do you
want to go up that ladder in that
factory or do you want to move up the
ladder that the marketing job will
provide
marketing wouldn't provide any kind of
uh upward trajectory it would just be
um because of the location that it's at
i would basically be doing
the same job i mean i could be there you
know 10 years but i'd be doing the same
job okay and so you don't want to go
into marketing you would rather go what
would be the uh upward mobility type
jobs at the factory that you're at
um
yo yo i could work in uh packaging i
could work you know just a lot of
different
jobs i mean
some of them i have no interest in but
some of them you know again would offer
more upward mobilities just there
i don't think i really have a passion
for them either okay so that's a problem
because my point is that's just a j.o.b
so you're talking about upward mobility
into something that you really won't
have any juice for
do you love the idea of doing marketing
forget that it's a limiting position in
that company but do you like the idea of
marketing is that something you enjoy
doing much more
yes okay then so here's why i want
here's why i would take the marketing
job
i take the marketing job to get out of
the factory world which you which you
don't want to do
i would get into the marketing world and
now we've got experience and oh by the
way a nice bump in pay is that true
yeah so we take the bump and pay we get
all excited about that but we're really
taking the job not for the bump and pay
we're taking it for the experience you
got your ticket into the marketing world
that experience that you're getting is
going to be huge for you and we know
going in i'm not going to be at this
company for a long time
because i want to move up george
and they're not offering the opportunity
to move up but it doesn't matter because
i can move up by moving on i understand
more options than races i don't see you
don't you're not stuck at this company
forever if you don't move up within a
few years and you feel like you've
gained experience guess what another
company is going to hire you for
marketing because of your experience
that's right so uh i take the marketing
job with a mind of i'm gonna do a good
job in the present
i gotta win in that role they'll be
looking six months to hit the eject
button and get out
i'm gonna go in and crush it
and i know i'm gonna crush it because
i'm gonna put everything i can into it
because i see a future in marketing and
i know that there is a much better
chance of me getting that future faster
if i win in the now and then the
opportunity for the next will come from
another company so you you have a false
narrative right now if i go to this
marketing company there's no opportunity
to advance that's not true
if you're good enough they'll create a
position for you or again you're not
limited to stay in that company you can
go move up by moving on so there you go
all right let's go to blake now in
atlanta georgia blake how can we help
hey how's it going today we're having a
blast what's going on with you it sounds
like it sounds like it um okay so quick
question i don't really know
exactly what to do about the situation
and i'm trying to find some some legal
advice as well i don't know the right
place me and ken are both attorneys yeah
george goes by esquire here in the
office we don't even call him george
great great great
um okay so i had a business prior to
cove but it was a remodeling business
i did very well coveted hit
a lot of my crews took unemployment a
lot of my guys
took you know loans for their own llcs
and and left and i made the decision at
that point in time
to try to survive and keep the business
going so i took out a loan it was an
unforgivable loan um at the time because
my my crews were not employed they were
all 10.99 none of them were w2 so i
could not get that forgivable loan
now i'm in a situation where my business
did not make it i had to go and get
another job and i'm you know i still
have this loan to pay back but i haven't
had you know it's a loan on a business
but i no longer it's no longer operating
that's a big problem blake it's one of
the reasons why we we especially
business owners tell them to do with
cash this is the equivalent of me taking
out a student loan and i don't finish
college there's no way to say well hey i
didn't finish college do i have to pay
it back yes you took out the loan how
much do you have
it said it's a 96 000 loan is that all
of your debt personal and business no no
i have a little bit more what else is
what else is there uh i have a i have a
car loan which i drive a car
that's about 30 grand and i have uh
i have student loans which is about 12.
how much is the car worth
in this market um
it's a brand new car
2022 35 36 000
well today you get to sell a car my
friend
because you can't i can't i i feel like
i can because you know i drive for my
current job
george was not george was not saying you
need to be fred flintstone i didn't say
you you can't drive a car i said you
can't drive a 36 thousand dollar car
when you're broke
you owe 30 on the car yes
yes
six grand go get yourself a six grand
car yeah i can fight i love while jordan
i'm gonna pull up some george help him
out of debt i'm going to pull up some
great five thousand dollar cars online
just to prove the point it's one of my
favorite things to do i always saw
canada use car salesmen no i'm just i'm
just an interweb researcher here we go
yeah so so just just real quick so i
tried to do that right i tried to do
that and every time i buy a used car
especially in that price range which i i
totally understand and i get that you
know i'm putting i'm constantly putting
money into it to stop buying cars get an
inspection
yeah i drive about 150 miles a day so it
needs to be a car that's extremely
difficult i got you blake get up george
help you i'll have suggestions shortly
let blake stop you're going to lose this
i'm going to help you out
i'm going to get him a reliable car for
five grand george help him out
blake we're getting a honda or toyota
sedan hey i'm i'm trying to come up with
those you're jumping ahead well i'm just
telling what he's gonna be looking for
you're gonna find the exact car and
prove to him that it's that it can be
found i'm going to the atlanta area you
can drive 150 miles a day on a honda
toyota and it'll go it'll run forever
you don't need a 30 000 car you're
justifying why you need a super
expensive car while you're broke because
you drive a lot that's true
right
i agree george what do you make what's
your income
uh about 150 000. what is some good news
blake that's awesome so once we sell
this car
you are down to your 12 000 in student
loan debt and then your business debt
correct
yes and so we're gonna do the debt
snowball we're gonna take all the money
you have and everything but a thousand
dollars we are throwing at that debt in
order the debt snowball smallest to
largest we're ignoring interest rate
we're gonna knock out the student loan
in a few months then we're gonna attack
the business loan with a vengeance and
then we're never going to touch debt
again agreed to agree
i agree boom
we got there and kenzar i'm seeing cars
on campus uh i've got a
subaru forester for 5200.
uh i got a ford focus
uh blake is gonna look so uncool in this
new car
i'm sorry ford fusion 4 800.
all of these not mechanically expensive
to keep up and i'm running out of time
i'd have much more but i've got to get
to a break blake you got this this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 dollars a year go
to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
welcome to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by george camel and we
are here for you this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
talking about your money life we're
talking about your relationships we're
talking about your work all of those are
interconnected and if you are losing in
any one of those areas it can affect the
others and we are excited that you're
here we're also excited to look out
into the lobby of ramsey solutions to
see
josh and emily on the debt free stage
welcome thanks for having us you bet
where'd you guys come in from sunbury
ohio all right very nice that sounds
lovely by the way well thank you yeah
absolutely and uh you guys are here to
do your debt free scream how exciting is
this oh we've been waiting this is
awesome all right let's get the details
all right so uh how much debt did you
pay off 149 thousand four hundred
dollars 149 400 and how much time did it
take to pay that off 22 months 22 whoa
we got george i detect some intensity
22 months all right and uh what was your
range of income during that time uh
started out at 120 000 and when we
finished we were at right at 200. oh wow
what do you guys do for a living i'm a
firefighter paramedic and i'm a software
engineer oh okay so uh what was the uh
cause of the bump
uh of about what eighty thousand dollars
i got i got a promotion nice way to go
mama and then i had a pay bump and a lot
of overtime whoa
so this is both of you getting after it
yeah oh that's awesome how tired are you
right now
it could be nap time
[Laughter]
that's awesome uh so what happened
22 months ago so it was the start of the
pandemic and i was taking care of all of
our finances and so all of that burden
fell on my shoulders and it always felt
like i you know he had to come to me and
say can we buy this can we fit this in
to the you know
can we afford this monthly payment and i
was always the no person or yeah we can
but deep inside it's like we really
shouldn't do this
wow and so what what happened then did
you know about ramsay solutions dave
ramsey what was the the moment where we
go okay who's going to help us do this
or how are we going to do this so emily
had actually um seen it on facebook
about the ads okay so because we're
doing two weeks free yes in the very
beginning the pandemic dave did a
two-week uh yes freeze trial
um so we binged watched um fpu
in that first two weeks my social media
team loves to hear that that's very cool
man the impact there so what kind of
debt was this um everything 21 different
accounts um what
anything from credit card student loans
multiple cars
um
time share wow
so you got out of the timeshare no no
that was not able to happen look we paid
it off okay yes paid it off well we know
that right how do you keep up with that
many accounts that feels stressful on
its own
right we had good online banking but
yeah just we didn't ever want to move
banks because i'm like there's so many
in there like i can't move them all so
wow
so i didn't detect
much of a story here uh josh so when
emily kind of brings this up she says
hey
facebook ad two weeks free
she brings it up to you i didn't detect
a lot of pushback did you jump in pretty
willingly yeah i did um
one of the big causes was when we were a
few months prior we had looked at you
know when could we retire how much is
this going to take
and when we looked at what we actually
had left over at the end of the month
we're like well we won't be able to
retire
wow and that's a was a big thing for us
you know what can we leave to our kids
what can we you know live on you know
after our work life is over
so when she found that online it was
like this is a blessing wow so you guys
binge watch
yes did you quickly get some momentum
was it hard to kind of get going talk to
us about after the binge it took us a
little while to
get through all the accounts and
actually list everything out and we were
still finding things that was huge an
eye opener we did an excel spreadsheet
and listed them all out i'm like shoot
there's 21 there
you know the hardest part is just
listing out all the debts not even
paying it off
oh my goodness so we got the ball
rolling and uh that was
definitely an eye-opener to see that we
could make this snowball work for us and
not against us and you realize you're
working too hard to be this broke you're
going we make six figures how can we not
do this i asked her that a lot
you know wow we can't afford this but we
make this much money
so was there a point in the journey so
we got a 22-month journey was there a
point you look back on you go okay we
got real momentum here we we felt it
then we were like okay now we can see
that this is going to happen
once the student loans went away i was
like
like those are finally gone we don't
want to deal with them anymore how much
of the 149.4 was the student loan
roughly oh gosh probably 45. wow
it's a big chunk there and then he sold
a bunch of stuff
what was the hardest thing to sell for
you emotionally
emotionally probably a uh a barn
actually the material for a barn that i
had bought a few years prior
well i was gonna put up on the property
and i said you know what
let's go and get rid of it take the
money i mean i sold that everything from
that to uh tools
and then just to finish everything off i
sold another truck wow so you delayed
the dream of the barn to clean up the
nightmare that was your reality wow
that's powerful that is strong so what's
the key what would you say to people
that are listening and watching your
story right now what's the key to
getting out of debt
i think just focus and paying attention
to what's going on around you so
you know we looked up and realized we
were almost 150 thousand dollars debt
and we didn't really even know how we
got there so you know understanding and
learning you know all about finances and
understanding that you know there's a
lot of money going out the door every
month and we had no idea where it was
going i can get yourself keyed in with a
with a support group with a key group of
um community members a big thing for us
was our church
that and a
non-profit for first responders with for
mental health and suicide prevention wow
so we were able to get really tight end
with a couple of key groups
and that helped a lot for that support
that's incredible well we're so proud of
you guys you're heroes
and thank you for your your service as a
firefighter that's that's absolutely
incredible so you guys had a lot of
cheerleaders did people think you were
crazy too
oh yeah yeah a lot of the people at work
definitely couldn't understand it
they're going what why are you doing
that yeah you don't need to be doing
that that's fine payments you can make
the payments
that's what they would definitely say
and now they're going wait how'd you do
that
tell me more it's amazing so we see uh
a little bit of that support group over
there to your right in the lobby we've
got the kiddos nicole and jared i mean
uh i mean we want to bring them up uh
but what does it mean when you look at
those kiddos now every night when you
tuck them into bed and know you guys are
debt-free
what does that mean to you as a dad as a
mom um
when i look at them truly i just think
that you know
they won't have to live through that
same thing they get to see the example
of
how to manage your finances um and we're
getting ready to start the kids program
the junior program with nicole how old
is nicole she's six almost seven and
jared is two oh my goodness so amazing
well a couple things we want to give you
uh to honor you hang on we we are they
ready is nicole gonna scream she's ready
to go we're not ready to go yet we got
some we got two gifts we want to give
you one we're gonna give you a copy of
dave's total money makeover for you to
give to somebody else and we're also
going to give you dave's latest book
baby steps millionaires because that's
what you're on the path to becoming and
you're going to do it and it's going to
be unbelievable so we want to give you
those two books all right so the kiddos
ready to go nicole have you been
practicing ready buddy she says yes
george she's ready to go josh
emily nicole and jared they're from uh
the columbia or columbus sorry ohio area
they paid off 149 400
in 22 months making 120 000 all the way
up to
200 000
josh and emily take it away it's time to
hear your debt free screen
three two one
little jared got into the act he was on
mom for a little bit and then he got
down and he's all fired up and uh george
what a what a lovely reminder of what
this is really about when we say things
like financial peace it has a very
personal application and in this case
look at the little man he's excited and
one day he'll get to watch this footage
and really understand what that
celebration really means i like to think
about that this will live on youtube
forever it'll still be around and he'll
go back and watch and say my parents did
that to change our family tree yeah i
love it man so good so proud of you josh
and emily two beautiful kids their lives
forever changed nicole and jared this is
why we do what we do this is why we're
here for you today there's somebody
listening somebody watching today that
feels like it is impossible
and i hope you've paid attention to just
a bit of the story that we heard from
josh and emily they did it
millions of others have done it and you
can do it too we believe in you we're
here for you stay tuned
more calls more breakthrough
coming up on the ramsay show
so
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman george a join rather
joined and george got a little too close
there joined by my colleague george
campbell was excited
yeah i'll tell you what i'm excited
about so we've been doing some fun uh uh
tick-tock videos you know where we show
a video and uh for our listening
audience you're gonna get to hear the
audio as well and we comment on it and
some of them have been stuff that we
think is kind of ridiculous
and uh so we uh we critique it uh if
nice way but it's a nice way to put it
now if dave's on he goes you know i mean
he's it's a rant
uh but that's what dave does we love
that about dave you know what i mean
spoils his supper but it makes for great
great uh broadcasting so today george
i'm teeing you up here because we have a
different clip one that we are not
critiquing we actually go you know what
some good stuff in this and maybe people
need to hear it from somebody else and
today our star
uh guest contributor via the old talk
there is i like to call it george hates
that um
is graham stefan
uh tell me about this graham stefan
cause he's in your lane you know you're
the millennial you're the cool kid
around the block i i got three teens
yeah so graham is he's 31 years old
close to my age and he is a he's a big
deal on youtube he's got 3.74 million
subscribers and his channel is all about
finances mainly he focuses on real
estate investing and other types of
investing and so he made a lot of money
at a young age in his 20s became a
millionaire all right through this
process and he he makes a whole lot of
money now about 6 million a year through
all of his youtube ad revenue
sponsorships affiliates that's
extraordinary and so he's a good kid we
disagree on a lot of things uh our views
on debt very different our views on
investing very different but i saw this
clip and i thought you know what he
actually has something interesting to
say here that i think we can all agree
with all right so let's roll it
i would say the smartest financial
decision was uh
probably investing in real estate and
and living no i would say is living
below my means living so extreme for so
long
i would say it really was not until
about
a year it was a year ago when i started
like
spending money
a year ago and even then it's it's not
been like frivolous stuff but
a year ago i wasn't even in here i was
in an 800 square foot duplex it was a
one bedroom one bathroom
um
worked from the garage and i had kept
that up i mean i was i was doing even
over a million dollars a year still
living in that same
800 square foot duplex in mid city like
this is i don't want to say it was like
a bad area but like when you think of
the income you you don't think of like
mid-city l.a
um
and uh yeah and i just didn't spend any
money and that was the best financial
decision ever this this house was the
first time i had ever done something for
myself was this
wow
look at that this is a youngster
uh
social media star living below his means
yeah and he started with my best
financial decision i ever made real
estate investing he goes no no yeah i
like that he backed it off you know what
it was living on less than i made and
that is a principle that we can
definitely agree on this man was
bringing in a million dollars a year
living in the 700 square foot place he
could have got a nicer place but he said
you know what i'm gonna sacrifice for a
period of time
so that i can achieve my bigger goals i
don't need to get all flashy now and
have this lifestyle creep now that i
make good money i'm gonna go spend it
and be real flashy and so i really
respect his hard work his sacrifice he's
a hard-working dude
even today making those youtube videos
is not easy and he puts in the work and
i think aside from you know
us disagreeing about leveraging debt and
doing the real estate his way i think we
can agree that we need more young people
who are willing to sacrifice who are
willing to not compare themselves to
other people that's right who are
willing to do the hard work to get to
where they want to go so what's at the
base of that george there's a real
takeaway too from this
because of a successful young guy like
this what he's saying is without saying
it
he was focused on the future not the
present
if i'm present focused hey i'm making a
million dollars i'm gonna start living
it up i'm gonna spend it if i'm future
focused i don't even realize i don't
even think much about my 800 square foot
duplex he didn't say that yeah but that
is synonymous among all successful
people whether we agree with the way
they handle their money or not
successful people have a focus on the
future they make decisions that are not
based on the now
they make decisions that are based on
the future so the now becomes
prioritized it's like i will make great
decisions in the now if i am focused on
how they affect my future that's another
big takeaway that i don't want young
people to miss one of our debt-free
screamers recently said you gotta have a
vision beyond friday oh boy man
i'd like to steal that yes i hope no one
was listening to that but i think that's
at the heart of that a lot of these
young people they follow graham they
follow his youtube channel they
subscribe because they want to be like
graham they want to be wealthy at a
young age they have options and freedom
and meaning and all this kind of stuff
they don't want to work till they're 65
in a job they hate you rally against
this stuff all the time ken but i think
at the heart of this the young people
need to understand that you can get rich
quick but you can lose it even quicker
oh boy and the way you keep your wealth
once you build it is by living on less
than you make it's truth
it's truth
just look up some of these high-profile
athletes that have blown hundreds of
millions of dollars he's one of my
favorite fighters of all time but if you
want to look out for the caution evander
holyfield my goodness gracious uh we're
talking about unbelievable earnings and
you can spend it so fast
so on the way up learn how to live on
the lesson you make really good stuff
george thanks for the clip yeah we had
to be a little bit positive see who says
you can't learn from the talk
well that's to be tbd
but there really is some great content
on the same people that are rallying
against tick tock are also watching
instagram reels and sending them to me
oh they're watching videos on facebook
let's be honest it's all the same videos
everybody's got their social media
opinion all right let's go to ben now
who joins us in phoenix arizona ben how
can we help
hey i appreciate you guys taking my call
and i appreciate you guys just doing
this it's very encouraging oh appreciate
the call man how can we help you today
so uh i am i've never been amazing with
money i'm kind of the opposite of that
last guy but i want to be better
but i've always kind of bought
everything i can and i finally just i'm
about to finish college and just got a
job where i feel like i'm i know it's a
stupid opinion but prior to now it
didn't feel like i made enough money to
save any money
and so i feel like i'm in a position
where i can and i'm trying to
be realistic and look at all my options
and i've been looking at the
benefits and my wife and i
are trying to have a baby right now and
i'm trying to decide on health care is
my main question
do you guys think it would be better
to go for a nicer healthcare plan that's
certainly more expensive
because we're trying to have a baby and
because we're likely going to need you
know a lot of that money
or to go for a cheaper one and do an hsa
i heard you guys talking about hsas the
other day and i don't know a lot about
them you guys seem like you kind of like
them but i don't know much about them
yeah absolutely that's a great question
and you're right there's a lot of
differences with healthcare plans when
you're looking at one and you're going
hey we're going to have a baby you may
not want to go with the quote cheapest
plan
in this stage of life now you can always
change health insurance down the road
but i would be talking with your
employer they probably have a point of
contact with the insurance company i'd
get in touch with the insurance company
and i'd find out exactly what this is
going to look like lay out the scenario
and say hey how much of the bill are we
going to have to foot if we have a baby
what does it cost what procedures what
appointments all of that and then you
can start to look at and go all right
it's a thousand dollars more but it's
gonna cover the procedure where we would
have been in the hole for two grand okay
this is worth it so you don't have to go
with the top of the tier health
insurance but i also may not choose the
lowest one either so maybe somewhere in
between but you've got to do some
research and get some more information
before you make a decision yeah and ben
you are not on your own george makes a
very good point your company will have
some representative who can at least
help you with all those
choices and decisions or they'll get you
in touch with the insurance company who
is the representative and
you need to take george's advice you'll
take the fear out of this you're quite
intelligent you can make the right
decision once you understand
all of the options so you know just look
at it
apples to apples you know pros cons you
and your wife and sit down and go what
do we think is best for us and i think
you'll find that you're going to have
some options and it's going to be okay
and i also want to say you know i got
three kids they're teens now
and uh george you're yet to be a dad i
hope you're gonna be dead you'll be a
great dad thank you but it is a scary
thing to bring a kid into your into your
world and it sometimes is scarier than
it needs to be
yes they are expensive no question man
they're like sinkholes we love them to
death uh but it's not as expensive in
some ways as you think you can do it if
it becomes a budget line item it becomes
a budget line item follow our steps here
ramsey solutions it's baby proof it
really is all right coming up next more
of your calls this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life by
being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful
financially i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague george campbell with a k thank
you very much triple 8
825-5225 is the phone number it is a
free call triple eight eight two five
five
two two five we'll talk about your money
issues your work issues your
relationship issues and just getting
going on a path forward so that you can
live the life that you desire to live
let's get started with mindy in
charlotte north carolina mindy how can
we help
hey ken and george thanks so much for
taking my call i'm excited to be on
today well we're excited to have you
what's going on yes so
yeah i am in what i would call a toxic
work environment
and all of my friends and family and
advisors are encouraging me to leave
however i don't have another job to go
to
so i'm wondering at what point do you
leave at what point in the toxicity do
you leave before having another job to
go to
unless it's abusive and i mean true
abuse
okay i mean something where it's like
get out of there today you you don't
feel safe
uh other than that i would not leave
until you have something else to leave
too unless mindy
you have
uh no debt
and you have a fully funded emergency
fund that you're not going to use
and maybe you've got some cash put aside
to allow you a 30 or 60 day window to
really go all in but again i just
very few people do that but i put it out
there as an asterisk for all the all the
cynics
i just don't think you have to do that i
think you can find a job if you get
really serious about it and you make it
your
primary focus outside of
taking care of yourself and
and staying employed so that we don't
have an interruption and a paycheck but
you can look and you can't find right
now charlotte north carolina uh at this
in this juncture of history uh that
particular market it is a job seekers
market right now i'd be shocked if you
can't find multiple opportunities to
make more than you're making now
so i want you to be careful
to find the right thing the other reason
i don't want you to jump is because i
want you to take your time you're tough
enough to deal with a little toxicity
you've done it up to this point because
now you know what to look for what to
avoid i don't want you to go from one
toxic environment to another that would
be very
very discouraging
mindy what job is this
i'm a customer service representative
okay and it's all in the office
um it's remote however i'm on the phone
with my boss most of the day and there's
yelling and hanging up on and
um so it's your boss specifically that
is the point of toxicity it's not the
company it's not the culture it's just
one person
correct so you're in customer service
but you spend most of the day on the
phone with your boss i don't understand
that
yeah we make um
we're a small company so we all wear a
lot of hats but yeah we make a lot of
sales calls together do you love this
company specifically
no no not even why can't you go find
another customer service job today there
are so many out there especially
remotely
yeah i can try it just it's been a rough
week and people are definitely on me to
quit right now so i've been like oh okay
i got it so mindy i'm glad you said that
um it's been a rough week
this guy's a jerk all caps
and that'll wear you down pretty fast
and then the people that you love and
trust the most are going get out of
there get out of there but the problem
is
financially that's not a good move i'm
guessing right
right you can't miss a paycheck can you
um not without going into my emergency
fund now no and don't do that do not
that is not an emergency
okay and so get after it mindy um love
the people
that are telling you this i love them
you love them
it's not their life it's not their
emergency fund that you're dipping into
right so i want you to just hold strong
right now and the next time you have an
awful phone call which is probably 12
minutes from now and the guy acts like a
jerk again you're going to be so tempted
to quit but you better quickly
look towards your future and go i don't
want to burn through my emergency fund
that i've worked so hard and put up with
this clown to fund right you got to go
hey i've got to find something else
that's better for me
and i'm going to find it because i can't
put up with this that much longer it
needs to drive your
intensity okay not drive you to make a
bad financial move and simply put you
leaving right now today without a job is
a bad financial move
yes all right appreciate the call you
got this mindy uh i'm telling you you
got it hey listen go to my website
kencole.com and download the resource uh
of the resume guide i think it might be
helpful to you to help stand out
we want to help you get connected better
get noticed better so go check that out
it's a free resource
uh let's go to brianna who joins us now
in the city of brotherly love
philadelphia pennsylvania brianna how
can we help
guys thank you so much for taking my
call you bet what's up
um so i was just calling my husband and
i um
we are on baby steps four five and six
um we both have 800 plus credit scores
and we have one card left open that we
just have one bill set up it just kind
of gets paid automatically every month
and paid in full to keep our credit
score up which i know
is not the rams ua i'm fine with closing
it out but my concern is that we still
have a first mortgage and we're planning
on moving in the next like two years or
so so we will need to apply again which
if our mortgage is still reporting
that's going to cause an issue when it
comes to manual underwriting from my
understanding so i'm not sure what to do
whether to close it out or not
um
so you're worried if you close it out
your your credit score takes a dip but
it doesn't disappear
right exactly i even called churchill
just to confirm and they were like yeah
no the mortgage is still going to be
reporting okay and you think you would
have a bad credit score at that point
i mean we're both 800 plus so i don't
know that it would drop to the point
where it would be an issue necessarily
i'm not sure how fast it would drop like
that i wouldn't be super concerned about
it and if it does become an issue you
can close out the account six months
later i mean you know once you you don't
have a mortgage anymore maybe you guys
rent for a little bit the credit score
disappears and then you can do manual
underwriting with no problem because you
don't have any open credit lines so that
it does pose an interesting uh scenario
when you already have a mortgage but you
guys want to buy another house correct
and you're gonna have another mortgage
yes yeah we would use the um proceeds
from the sale of this home to put
towards the next house how close could
you be to paying cash for your next
house
um i mean we owe about 115 on this right
now it's worth probably like 200 so we
have a pretty good down payment but i
mean we can stay in it longer than the
next two years but
it's just kind of tight
yeah
well and if you close out the credit
card i'd be curious to see what happens
to your credit score i don't think it's
going to tank if you keep paying your
mortgage and your bills regularly
without issue i think it'll stay high
and i don't you know i don't want that
but hey you can do it and you get the
other mortgage with a good credit score
and you'll be just fine the only thing
it would affect is your interest rate
and at that point if following our plan
that house is going to be paid off so
fast that we're not even concerned with
the interest payments
that is a valid point that i did not
consider so that's definitely our plan
that's a win
that's why george comes to work every
day he just nailed it it's rare that
anyone says i have a valid point
including my wife is that right so
that's a win from briana brianna thank
you for the call you've got a plan now
and thank you for making george's heart
swell
with pride he's such a great three sizes
bigger this day well you better be
careful that shirt that shirts are small
be careful hey
coming up next more of your calls here
on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back america you're joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman jordan joined by my
colleague george kimmel and uh hey uh
how many of you out there would like to
do work you really love
in a place
that aligns with your values i would
love that would you like that i'm doing
it right now yeah you are and that's
it's ironic that you say that because we
are hiring at ramsey solutions and we
need really smart people george
absolutely these are much smarter people
than me with emotional intelligence that
would be great you can have both okay
soft skills and hard skills well you
know where i'm going
ux designers developers writers to help
us build digital products that actually
change people's lives if you want to see
what it's like to work here before you
apply follow us on instagram and
facebook by searching ramsey careers
we need you
and if you'd like to do work that
matters with us
apply for your dream job at
ramseysolutions.com careers that's
ramsey solutions
dot com
slash
careers
when you said we need you it reminded me
of the uncle sam poster and i thought we
didn't uncle dave poster you know what
that would be some good marketing next
time i'm on with him i'm gonna steal
that unless you do it first now you got
this because he'll get so irritated by
that he would be like
he might be tickled by it we don't know
but seriously i love this place and it
really is one of the nicest buildings
i've been in on top of the amazing team
the culture the work that we get to do
the impact it's fantastic i met my wife
here been here nine years now well now
george that's a high bar high bar i know
you might meet your future spouse here
is an amazing woman the only thing wrong
with whitney is poor judgment yeah but
hey caught her at the right time yes you
did and good for you
don't tell me george campbell can't sell
thank you you did it ramsay solutions
dot com slash careers come join us love
to see you can see me and ken in the
cafeteria yeah nobody cares okay triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five two two
five ryan is on the line in orlando
florida oh the whole of disney george
very exciting ryan how can we help
oh hello uh ken and george uh thank you
for taking my call you bet what's up um
well um i am currently 48 years old and
i've been an engineer for about 15 years
um i have a very good and secure job
but i have been interested for a while
in changing careers all together okay um
and so um right now i'm in baby step
three and i was curious as to when is a
good time to actually start to
um
to where within the baby steps is a good
time to um begin the career change
journey oh i love you a little more
specifically
well just to be a little specific i have
a program that's a 10-week program so
i'd have to take some time off from work
because it's full-time so that's why i'm
wondering what is it
so the 10-week program is what's
necessary to be qualified to change gigs
yes do you have to take 10 weeks of work
off
uh yes because it requires being there
full time and my um the work that i do
also requires full-time so something's
got to give so what happens after the
10-week program
um i would return back to
my job i wouldn't quit it right away of
course um because there's going to be a
lot that needs to be done to prepare for
the other career
but uh i just want to make sure that
financially i would be yeah okay
yeah that's what i was wondering yeah so
uh yeah and i'm going to get to that but
how are you going to take 10 weeks off
of your current employment
and then not be a problem you don't have
10 weeks of vacation do you
um i can if i work long enough i might
be able to actually accumulate about
eight weeks and so then at least two
weeks that will probably have to be
leave without pay
and that doesn't you know have enough
food to be okay i know but here's i'm
coming to the financial but there's some
background before i can give financial
advice as it relates to changing careers
so let's play that out you've got let's
say you do have eight weeks you think
you can
uh we need to know we can because now we
got two weeks of
unpaid leave does that not create
question marks that could make it pretty
rough on you returning back to this job
that you said that's part of the plan
honestly i don't know i haven't gone
that far yet you have two questions yeah
that's okay
well but hey that's why you called so
that's what i'm doing i'm walking you
through what you need to know i'm really
concerned
about this plan
uh involving you returning back to the
place you're at where you're at now that
you don't want to be
and uh the two weeks of unpaid leave
that's going to generate all kinds of
questions from your leader unless
they've got their head completely in the
sand
and that could create problems for you
[Music]
can you not do the 10 weeks uh in in i
don't know how to ask this um
is there not another way to do the 10
weeks where you wouldn't have to take
off 10 weeks of work meaning you do it
at nights and weekends or am i am i is
that a totally silly question
no it would not be i would not be able
to um i'm actually interested in um
carpentry okay so the program is
basically working in the daytime oh okay
so you want to be a carpenter
yes oh my goodness okay so let me ask
you this why can't you walk out of the
10 week training program right into a
job
that's a good question i did not
consider okay so
now we got the background because i want
to answer this question for the entire
audience not just ryan
on when in the baby steps
should i change jobs i'm going to answer
that in a minute so i haven't left i
just wanted everybody to know what get
into that yeah i'm teasing it ryan in
your situation
i don't understand why
if you haven't gotten that carpentry
training or licensing or whatever it is
is it a certification
um it's actually a beginning because i i
have
zero experience in it so that's why i
was figuring on being in the program and
then possibly taking other courses
because i'm actually interested in
incorporating that with um some
architecture courses as well i
understand but you need a job and so you
cannot take 10 weeks off
without pay you're gonna end up losing
your current job
so we've got two ways we go about this
either you just buckle down and you
press pause
on the carpentry
training
until you have
let's call it to be safe three months of
living expenses above and beyond your
emergency fund
you see you have to have what i would
call a floating fund here we don't can't
interrupt income and so if we're going
to take the carpentry school that'll
then bring in money we still got to be
able to to pay the bills you understand
what i'm saying so this is going to be
wait longer
to be able to take the carpentry deal or
go back and do more homework and find
out could i go in and start slinging a
hammer after this 10 week course i gotta
tell you in the construction world i
shared this on the show the ramsey show
two days ago i talk about it every day
on the ken coleman show i was on
mornings with maria on fox business
george yesterday talking about the
trades and how construction workers are
needed everywhere i just think that you
can make this transition
ryan so go find out go ahead george i
know you're gonna say so i'm just
curious what job are you doing now ryan
i'm an engineer okay and what do you
make
95 000.
so the question is if you have an
entry-level carpentry job not going to
make 95. are you is that going to hurt
you financially can you live
well uh as you were saying i would
definitely have to make sure i have a
good enough savings before i could do
something one baby step right now i
believe i could live what baby step
huh three three how close to how close
to fully funding that are you
oh um i just started baby step three i
just finished um paying off my vehicle
okay so this could be another four five
six months for you to get your emergency
fund in place
yes see in the emergency fund is not
this what i call a floating fund i
didn't have another word for george the
emergency fund is not for the job you're
planning to take this 10-week course
you're planning to be away from the job
so it's not an emergency yeah so it's
the emergency fund can't be used for job
transition is what we teach
so back to the bigger question for ryan
and everybody else
you can change jobs at any point in the
baby steps as long as
there is not an interruption in income
and not a sizable
serious
backwards movement in pay yeah so if we
if we if we have parallel pay
and then we or we have more pay that
only helps us i think we need to look
into more options for how to get this
carpentry skill set going and maybe it's
trade school at night yeah and i also
think she needs to do more homework
because i don't know that she wants i
heard architecture
um
ryan i want you to delay this move until
you know what you can actually make
slinging a hammer because it's going to
take longer to move into the
architecture piece anyway more homework
how do i get there what's it going to
cost me how long is that going to take
in light of no debt and working through
the baby steps but it's a really good
question and i really appreciate it
folks you can change jobs in the baby
steps just no interruption of income
all right don't move more ramsey show
coming up
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by george campbell
and uh george you know there's a
cultural myth
that i don't have time to break down as
to how it started it's just not enough
time
but there is a myth
that
the best way the only way to be
successful professionally and
financially is if you have a college
degree like it's a magic ticket to a
better future well i think more and more
people are becoming aware that that's a
myth george so
i wrote a blog for the mothership ramsey
solutions.com it's entitled 25
high-paying jobs that don't
require
a four-year degree and so you and i uh
this is a reveal it's kind of fun for us
we chose during the break some of our
favorite jobs and why in this category
yeah so um
based on our last call i thought i'd
start with one of mine okay hit me um
and we had ryan on the line and she
wants to uh she's in the process of is
is she gonna decide to take a carpentry
course
to become a carpenter well it just so
happens that
one of the 25 high paying jobs that
doesn't require four year degree is
carpenter
and the median salary now let me explain
this to some folks because i've done
social media posts george get crushed on
tick tock because people don't pay
attention they don't understand i didn't
say it's the income i'm saying it's the
median let's explain what median is
george tell folks at home median means
middle middle so if you take the high
not average by the way middle so if you
take the high across the country all 50
states
and you take the low
this is the median the middle
of the range you're learning
great you'll learn this you didn't learn
after that well but people don't care on
social media they just want to hammer
you so here we go our pun there thank
you very much
you know what james is gonna i'm gonna
hear about that one later that's perfect
i don't even know i said that
oh boy okay so what's the median salary
for carpenter folks forty nine thousand
five hundred dollars education needed
high school diploma and some form of
apprenticeship so there you go what do
you got george i have electrician
another trade i just had an electrician
at the house oh yeah and then i got the
bill and i went oh boy
okay hey he's doing well but i'm not
messing with those wires no okay and
median salary for electricians 57 000
education needed diploma apprenticeship
and there's positive job growth in that
area okay all right let's go a little
more high-tech george what about a
radiologic or mri technologist oh that's
a good one now this isn't going anywhere
this is healthcare right like you talk
about stability george also pays really
well median salary 63 700 10
what education do you need associate
degree only so boy that's that's budget
friendly i like that that's a two-year
community college let's go let's go
let's go
without the tag from med school that's
right leaving the old bill there yeah
nice okay this one's personal this one's
close to home executive assistant was
number 11 on your list i know why median
salary 63 000 and education needed high
school diploma and this is close to home
because my wife is an executive
assistant here at ramsey solutions and
if you know ramsey solutions and you
know that the crowd here we have a huge
huge team of assistants yeah and then on
top of that there's executive assistants
that serve our operating board members
our senior leaders and my wife is one of
those rock star executive assistants
that serves someone on our operating
board that reports to dave and she
crushes it and so i think that's a great
great option for folks out there uh
beyond the old school mentality of a
secretary this is so much more this is a
partnership with leaders to help them
accomplish what they want they truly are
the gatekeepers that make the world go
round it's basically they're ceos that's
how i like to see it all right here's
let's do a couple more real quick
occupational therapy assistant this is a
median salary of 60 950 only need an
associate degree and listen to this if
you're in the people business you love
taking care of others you would call
yourself a caretaker great job here this
is all about helping people learn and
practice skills to live and work most of
it takes place after someone has had
some type of accident or elderly people
who need performing help performing
daily tasks around their homes so
another a really people-centric job good
money yeah let me hit you with one more
this is a big one web developer oh yeah
man median salary 77 000 yeah and
education needed an associate's degree
and even now there's so many options out
there affordable courses online and
companies are so hungry for web
developers i mean we are hiring them
like crazy right now here at ramsey
solutions and you don't need to go to
the fancy name brand school to get the
degree in computer engineering software
engineering and there's some crazy
growth in that area and by the way
that's the median salary you're going to
be in the six figure range pretty quick
if you are good
let me also tell you if you have people
skills as a developer watch out all
right one more we got to give one that
is a associate's degree required only
and george's is over six figures high
demand now it's high stress so if you
are a low pulse kind of person you
handle high stress pretty easily air
traffic controller might be
the gig for you airplanes aren't going
anywhere median salary george you ready
for this 130 000
dollars so there you go that's median
yeah if you'd like to see the entire
list dive into it a little bit more to
learn what it takes to win in those
areas uh you can search that blog up
ramseysolutions.com 25 high paying jobs
that don't require a four-year degree
all right let's get back to the phones
the phone number for you to jump in uh
on the line today is triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five
samantha is up in dallas texas samantha
how can we help
hey guys um so i recently inherited
three hundred thousand dollars whoa
yes it's exciting but i'm like stuck on
what to do i'm thinking i want to buy a
house but i'm confused if i should like
just use it all and buy the house in
full or save some invest some i just
suck
well samantha where did this money come
from
uh my grandma oh
well that's very sweet what a legacy to
leave
yes very cool okay so do you have any
debt currently
no i paid it off yesterday what
congratulations that's amazing so how
much money do you have to your name
right now in cash in savings
uh i mean in savings i have started my
emergency fund now i'm only at 4 000.
okay well today you get to fully fund
that emergency fund congratulations
okay and then with what's left i want
you to be investing for the future i
want you to be investing that 15 of your
household income but that can be done
through your cash flow through your
future paychecks so this money okay if
you're is a house the next goal for you
financially are you renting right now
i'm renting yeah okay
and have you looked at homes in your
area that would be reasonable that you'd
be okay living in in the dallas texas
area
yeah okay
i i'm assuming you're gonna have a hard
time paying cash for a place in that
price range am i wrong
uh yeah probably it would be a good down
payment but the ones
in my price range might not be in the
best areas
okay so if you're looking i'm gonna
start doing some research and go okay
what's it gonna cost and i know i can
put you know 70 80
down as a down payment that's going to
make your mortgage payment super super
tiny and that's going to help you pay it
off really really fast and then
how much do you make
66 000 a year wonderful now imagine
making 66 000 a year and you get to keep
every penny after you pay your taxes
it's not going to a mortgage lender it's
not going to payments
that is what's going to help you create
wealth so i would be throwing the rest
of the money beyond the emergency fund
at your next home purchase trying to pay
cash or putting down a huge down payment
if possible do it on a 15-year fixed
rate and pay it off as fast as you can
how old are you
29. oh my goodness oh this is so
samantha you're going to be so
unbelievably wealthy and part of that is
due to the legacy that grandma left you
and i think she'd be she'd be smiling
about this situation
okay great well thank you guys so much
yeah thank you for calling i love the
advice george you know what to young
people
be patient on the house man
it's so worth waiting yeah you know i
mean i think about how many houses
stacey and i are so we're coming up on
24 years of marriage
and um we're now in our
fifth house
and i look back on the first house we go
oh it's great we have great memories but
like we didn't
we didn't we weren't dumb with buying it
but we could have waited yeah we could
have waited and saved the money because
we were only at two years before we
removed for work and we didn't make much
on i think we cleared seven grand or
something on that first sale of the
house and i just think i just think back
i go i think i would have rather rented
yeah and kept steven saving that money
investing that money wait and wait and
wait and wait until you can go so much
into that down into that uh payment
where you have no payment at all or such
little payment you can pay it off in
short for a short matter of time like
you and your wife did yeah i mean you
gotta stop putting pressure on these
young people to get houses immediately
yeah because you could beat george
campbell who doesn't want to be george
campbell a lot of people no house
payment he's saving them for the big boy
let's go oh it's going to be a palace
are you going to invite me over yeah
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
national based world headquarters i'm
ken coleman
joined by george campbell for taking
your calls triple eight eight two five
five two two five money calls
relationship calls work calls you just
wanna win in those three areas
and you're not winning to the rate that
you want to be winning or you feel stuck
or scared or unsure where to go we're
here for you triple eight eight two five
five two two five um i could not be any
more excited
that the ramsey 18 wheeler george
is uh warming up in the parking lot
uh just got an email you and i got an
email today we did fall live event fall
live event schedule we've already got a
couple on the spring schedule that's
what i want to talk about very briefly i
thought they'd never let us out of here
ken i know i know we are coming back on
the road uh building wealth is the event
that uh we're most excited about because
it's coming up in may two great cities
las vegas and orlando couldn't be any
different when you think about the
makeup of those cities and
geographically opposite sides of the
country geographically different we're
going to be uh at those two cities with
a great event called building wealth
obviously i think the pandemic in many
many ways made us focus on the future so
much more than we probably had been and
building wealth is a big part of that
focus and a lot of people are freaking
out because of inflation george gas and
groceries man they're killing people
killing us and so we're going to talk to
you
and show you how to build real wealth
the financial principles we teach are
the only principles that work in
prosperous times and hard times and
you're going to become a baby steps a
millionaire if you follow those steps so
join me
george campbell dave ramsey rachel cruz
dr john deloney as we uh
come together
on one stage for a great fun night
yesterday i did try to get a yes or no
on a tiger and uh uh pete young who is
our uh uh lovely and fantastic vp of
live events said he loved the idea he
didn't say yes or no he just said he's
so kind he said love the heart behind it
yeah yeah he's very nice guy he's very
nice we're not going to have a tiger uh
but we are going to be there thursday
may 5th in orlando thursday may 19th in
las vegas that's going to be fun
building wealth tickets start at just
25 for the individual or you can get a
four pack for only 60 bucks so my
goodness steep discount that's a george
camel hack the money you save you can
hit the slots after the event oh boy i'm
not sure that's what we want okay but uh
but uh you know better than your tiger
idea it well i don't know george the
tiger doesn't cost you you're not
throwing away money
that's true yeah so anyway this is a
great deal
don't wait go to ramseysolutions.com
events to learn more go to
ramseysolutions.com
events are you going to wear sequins i
don't know
rock sequence
regardless of the environment or
location dr don uh dr john delaney
rather uh said he might wear a boa
that's a visual i don't want to ever see
again you got to come to las vegas to
find out if any of any of that's going
to happen but until then back to the
phones we go bob is joining us in
ventura california bob how can we help
hey ken hey george thanks for taking my
call you bet what's up
before i get started ken do not give up
on that tiger game please please keep it
i see the people don't encourage him bob
if bob listen would you come to the
vegas event if you knew there was going
to be a tiger in a cage on the stage
with dave ramsey
absolutely see i i'm trying to move
tickets bob i'm trying to move tickets
but we'll see i don't i'm not going to
quit on it bob thanks to you
well hey thanks guys i've been listening
for a couple years and i was looking for
a clarification on ramsey suggested
guidance which i had not heard before
so you all suggest that match uh with
respect to retirement savings that match
beats roth beats tradition yes and the
recommended amount in baby steps four
five and six is fifteen
um if it's traditional uh
that that's clear in terms of the amount
of your income going into the retirement
dissolved so for example
if i make 100k and i'm putting 15 then
15k gets into my traditional
i am at the point where i want to start
investing in my 401k raw
so is it
in that example is it 15k that would go
into my roth or is it 15 of my income
uh so a smaller amount goes into roth so
you know right one percent of gross
versus 15k going into the loss
either way it's going to be 15
of your gross income but you're right
that if you put it in roth that's with
after tax dollars which means it's going
to grow tax-free you can withdraw it
tax-free and retirement so in that
regard you investing 15 your roth is
actually going to cost you a little more
but gain you more uh in retirement in
that sense
because you've already paid taxes on
that money so yes we we save 15 of your
gross household income into retirement
we love the roth option if you've got
that that's what i do here at ramsey
solutions i do all 15 into our roth 401k
and we get a match on top of that
because we have great investing options
and then when i retire if there's two
million dollars sitting in that account
i actually can pull out two million
dollars tax-free and so i love the roth
big fan of that and if you can swing it
with the 15 to the roth that's what i
would be doing bob
well hey uh thanks george thanks for
your advice i appreciate the
clarification there and uh keep up the
good work guys yeah thank you sir thank
you for endorsing the idea of the tiger
las vegas building wealth event
george the people man no wait a second
bob is a representative of many many
more people george i'm convinced of it
we'll see megan's up in dallas texas
megan how can we help
hi
thank you so much for taking my call you
bet um so i was actually in a car
accident in february oh no are you okay
i'm okay yeah
it's been a journey but um i did just
receive a check from the insurance
company it was a total
and so um
where i am financially is i have
a 9 000 so far in my emergency fund i'm
debt-free
um and so seeing this check i received
24 000 for my car um
and just seeing that land and my account
is making me rethink
um how much i should be spending on a
car um what are you thinking
well i mean initially i just thought i
would just
like apply the entire check um to a new
car
um but just looking at the prices and as
i've been shopping for the last month
it kind of makes me sick to think that
that
value of my car could go down you know
in the near future
um
so i'm just wondering if it'd be a good
play to get something like
that would tie me over and see if this
car market changes
because the car that i that was totaled
um i purchased for 16 and they just paid
me 24.
absolutely oh yeah
it just kind of makes me sick to drop
that kind of money um so what's your
what's your like
what's a good measure um my gross is 40
i bring home about 2 700 a month nice
what was the other car if you don't mind
me asking give me the year and mileage
um my car was a 2016 raw4 and it had
around 67 000 miles
okay so here's our parameters megan to
make it real easy for you we don't want
you to have more than 50
of your income tied up with things in
motors
so i'm guessing the car is the only
thing you own that has a motor in it no
boats no big toys correct
so in your scenario you're making 40k i
don't want you to own a car that's worth
more than 20k
so you're right i don't think you need a
24 000 car just because they cut you a
check instead let it help you get ahead
financially and get a reasonable car
because you're right this market is
insane so if you can avoid getting an
expensive car in this market you're
doing all right and i don't want you to
buy a new car until you're a millionaire
so we're going to get a new to megan
carr
that is used and i would be looking at
something reliable you had a toyota big
fan of toyota big fan of honda and so i
would be looking at something like that
they're making fun of how i say toyota i
don't know toyota they're in race george
i just want to make sure the listener
and the viewer knows what we're talking
about i mean i have no problem we've got
bigger problems to face here so did you
like your rav4
well i did but i kind of had my eyes set
on um
on a
i'm sorry sometimes i blink yeah so do i
don't worry about it
yeah
i uh
oh and i'm on the radio yeah don't worry
about it was it toyota it's just another
mid-sized suv no um yeah all right
here's the point go look at them yeah
and and stay in that price range that
you feel comfortable with
right and make sure whatever you buy you
do a pre-purchase inspection it is worth
the money and don't get suckered in with
all these fees and warranties they try
to sell you i want you to look at that
contract and make sure there's nothing
more than a small doc fee if anything
and your sales tax so don't get suckered
in in today's market yeah i gotta tell
you i know george agrees with me on this
i'm a big toyota so they also make
alex's older lexus honda he's a big
honda like you got a pilot you know
looking at range and something a little
bit older but all in it's not going to
cost 20k yeah yeah don't and then spend
less you still get something reliable
george campbell great job this hour i
want to thank our team in the booth back
there making it all happen and you
america this is your show this is the
ramsey show
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we help you live your best life
by being healthy relationally successful
professionally and peaceful financially
i'm ken coleman george campbell is with
me and we are here for you triple
a825225
triple eight eight two five five
two two five let's go to columbia south
carolina brian is on the line brian how
can we help
how you doing guys how are you we are
having a blast
good i have a question for you um i'm a
real estate investor and um my net worth
is about uh 2 million maybe a little bit
over
um my my net income is about 8 500 right
now and in december it's going to be
going to 10.5 a month
um so as i said i'm a real estate
investor and i have this whole life
policy that i took out at the age of 26
and another one at the age of 33.
the cash value on both those
policies together is about 70 000 and
the death benefit on those both together
would be 107.
i'm looking to take that money out it's
just sitting there doing nothing really
but then on the other side of the coin
if i close those accounts out then i'm
losing on the debt benefit of 107.
that's totally fine with me
because you're going to get a term life
policy before you cancel this whole life
i was just going to say that should i
take out a term policy and cover that
107
100 and then take that 70 and then just
use it yeah i want you to get a term
policy that's 10 to 12 times your income
and i guarantee you it'll still be
astronomically cheaper than what you're
paying for this whole life policy right
now it's a total rip off
well i'm not i'm not paying anything for
it because i took it out when i was very
young and right now the dividends are
paying the premiums but there's still
there's agent commissions fees there's
all kinds of things that are wrapped in
there
yeah you think they're not making money
off of you they are buddy so here's what
i would do get a turn policy in place
contact our friends at xander insurance
they'll get you started there i just did
this actually upgraded my own term life
and it was a great process
once you have the term life policy in
place until it's active don't cancel the
whole life once it is active right
cancel the whole life get the cash value
out of there and you'll be set
right i understand the only thing is i
hate taking on more debt you guys are
really
big on having no debt and i get that and
i love that the only that i had to have
is right now is the house that i live in
my primary and a car and that's pretty
much it all my properties that i have
are paid in full wonderful um
so that that's that's great i have four
properties that are all paid in full and
that's kind of my income along with my
social security uh money that i have in
coming in cool well i'll pay off that
car if you get that cash value out i'm
getting completely debt free are you
investing 15 of your income
yes okay so beyond that we're going to
pay off the house with whatever money is
left over
right then imagine making your money
without a payment in the world
so yeah so the main thing is to take
this 70 000 and then just use that and
take the term policy and cover the 107
death benefit that i'd be losing yeah
the 107 you're saying 107 000 if you
died
today that's right that sucks
you need way more than that and so a
term life policy is going to be way
cheaper
and you can get that for 10 times your
income let's say let's just say you get
a
1.5 million policy it might be a few
hundred bucks a year
you can cover that yeah especially with
the preferred rate i want you to do your
investing and your insurance separate
and the problem with whole life is it
tries to do two things at once and it
sucks at both
i don't mind so much losing the 107 on
this death benefit because my assets
would cover anything from my death in
the event you're not going to lose
anything once you get that term life in
place instead of 107 benefit you're
going to have a 1.5 million dollar
benefit for a fraction of the cost
oh great that's what i was looking for
yeah you're not losing anything here
yeah at all so by the way
you won't miss that benefit yeah and uh
word to the lies get yourself in premium
shape before you take that term life
insurance yes you don't want to have a
gap there so make sure you get term life
in place then cancel whole life it's one
of the worst products out there the only
people who benefit from it are the whole
life salesman imagine that because it's
not insurance
it's trying to be too many things at
once don't like it not your fans george
are you you okay i'm sorry i get riled
up and i mean you just got a little hot
under the collar about whole life
insurance nonetheless yeah wow but he's
doing so great i want to protect his
assets and all the stuff he's working so
hard for don't apologize for passion
okay i love it you ready to go though
i'm ready you settled down
all right coach adrian is up next in
milwaukee adrian how can we help
hi um can you hear me okay we can
great um thank you first of all for for
taking my call i i'm so excited um
i i've been listening to you guys for a
couple of months now and i'm calling
because
i'm a single mom of a 12 year old and
her entire life we've lived in extreme
poverty wow
and
i um i'm legally i'm going to cry i just
can't that's okay
adrian hey listen we're here for you
take your time it's okay to cry this is
painful stuff we're not gonna leave you
hanging
take your time i just uh
it's i feel like
every time i try to get up something
happens and i get knocked down
and
if y'all didn't know this and i know you
do child care is expensive
and so i've often had to stay home with
her
and i have a degree i actually have a
degree in teaching and and people ask me
and i don't mean to throw this at y'all
but it's okay people ask me you know why
are you not teaching
well when i was a student teacher i was
uh sexually assaulted by a gang that's
now famous ms-13
you arrest me with ptsd oh i'm so sorry
and i just
it's just
it's just been difficult the last five
years especially to
watch them grow and become famous and
when they announced a year and a half
ago terrorist charges for their leaders
i had severe memory loss and i got help
i went to a psychologist and
you know we talked through it and
everything so
uh i know you're you're online and
everything i just
i um adrian let me ask you this are you
healthy enough
are you healthy enough after the
counseling the therapy that you've
gotten to do other type of work that are
not that maybe not in that environment
that is so painful
yes okay yes and that's why i'm calling
because i know i'm crying because i just
can't believe you took my call
but the answer to that is yes and
um my daughter and i went together in
the recovery center end of 2021 and they
knew what's going on and it was for
protection too
um are you living in a safe place now
where are you two living now
i am we are um actually
north of milwaukee and we live next to
our town's police department so we're as
safe as we're going to get
well no you're safe as you can be in
public housing am i understanding you're
still in public housing oh yes we are
yeah the nail on the head okay so uh
adrian we we want to help you so we're
going to hold you over we got to go to a
commercial break george is ready to go
we're going to help you get your money
game figured out i'm going to help you
figure out how we can get some work that
is healthy and also making enough money
for you to be able to crawl out of this
because you can but crawl is probably
the key word here so here's what i want
you to do
take a deep breath get yourself a glass
of water hang on through the commercial
break when we come back we're going to
pick her up right where we left off
which is how can we get you good work to
start bringing more income so we can
begin to build
financial peace hang on we're going to
help you out you're a sweet lady the
best is yet to be i promise this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free
whitepaper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back folks you're joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show
going into our last commercial break we
had been talking with adrian
or adrian in the milwaukee wisconsin
and she and her 12 year old daughter
have been
in public housing for some time
she's dealt with a lot of trauma in her
past
and
essentially she's going help
get me out of public housing
and so george and i are going to dive
back in here we want to work on income
first and then what do we do with that
income for a better life so we're going
to go back to adrian adrianne okay so
let's talk about income we we know
you've been through a lot we want to
focus on the future and so you've got a
college degree you've been a teacher so
you've got a lot of transferable skills
and you have transferable experience
and i think in this job market adrian
we're talking about the lowest
unemployment rate in the history of this
country right now
it is a job seekers market i can give
you some resources at the at the end of
our call
but i just want you to give me one or
two things that you know
that you can do and do a good job of
that's going to pay you enough money to
get out of poverty level give me two
ideas real quick
oh
um
online remote teacher okay rather than
be in the in the classroom all right
that's a good one
um i actually took your career
assessment last night and it suggested
um social justice advocacy human and
civil rights but i don't really know how
that transfers you know to an actual
specific job okay so glad you took the
get clear career assessment those are
just pointing you in directions
so you want to look at things like
social service social work
okay i'm not saying these are things
that you automatically should do i'm
just saying you have to brainstorm a
little bit
and the best way to brainstorm is
actually get on job sites
in milwaukee and begin to see who's
hiring
and can i do things where i love on
people
right because that's what you want to do
you have the gift of instruction
so you could take a training job maybe
an hr training job there's so many
different things that you can do because
of your degree and because of your
background in teaching people so i want
you to begin to believe
that you can actually make really good
money right now
you can make good money you can be
making forty thousand fifty thousand
sixty thousand dollars you can do that
and that's going to take care of the
public housing problem and your
daughter's 12 and if you're in a safer
place i'm a father so please understand
what from which i come from on this
she's 12. if you're in a safer place and
you said you're in a safe place now she
can stay home uh in between the time she
gets off of school and you get off of
work and so there is a path forward for
you do you see that
i do i absolutely do and that's a huge
reason why
why i called him all right great now
let's talk about the money situation
george jump in here on what she's doing
where she's at and how she can so what
is your income now and where is it
coming from
uh
i was working at a restaurant by where i
lived
over the winter because my car died
my income is only a thousand a month
okay so a thousand a month and where is
that coming from
currently
mcdonald's okay so you've got a
part-time job there right now
i had to quit it the other day well
actually i gave them two months
um because the work gave me a um
it gave me a i'd go to the emergency
room because my rib cage is inflamed oh
that's why i said okay i could quit but
i'm gonna give you you know a length of
time declared me come to work they said
you can go now so you don't have income
right now
no we just dropped to zero like yeah
sweetheart
we need to cover your four walls food
utilities housing and transportation we
have to have food on the table we have
to be able to cover your rent whatever
that is how high is the rent for you
none
okay because of public health they're in
public housing okay and then
transportation do you have a car
no
so you're walking they told me that i
either i walk to work and i walk through
the smell and i walk through the ice um
my car the apartment complex said um
this is a little bit ago they said hey
you fixed it today or we're telling it
adrian you've got to go get a job as
soon as possible we've got to get you
some health insurance in place we've got
to get some stability here with the four
walls before we can do anything else
we've got to keep food on the table
we've got to cover the bills and we've
got to do that asap this is your a1 and
we also have to get you healthy so we
want to send you some resources one of
those things is dr john dolone's new
book that's coming out soon own your
past change your future it's going to
help you deal with all the trauma that
you've experienced it comes with a month
of therapy from better help weekly
counseling that's going to be helpful
and ken can also send you a copy of his
book yeah we're going to give you a copy
of from paycheck to purpose because you
have got to take care of you and your
daughter financially you've got to get a
job and you can
you're going to have hardships but you
need more income
bigger paycheck and then we'll help you
walk through that let's also get her a
copy of total money makeover so that you
know how to spend your money
how to start a great financial
foundation we're so sorry for what
you've gone through but you have
survived it which tells me
that days of thriving are just around
the corner but it starts with you
getting busy
and getting out of public housing that's
going to lift you not just financially
but lift you emotionally and allow you
to do what you need to do to get healthy
and take care of that baby girl thank
you so much for listening and thank you
for the call alexa is on the line in
denver colorado alexa how can we help
hi there how are you guys doing great
how can we help you
um so i just want some i guess some
input from you guys um my husband and i
are currently on baby step number two
um we should be done with that and
halfway through our emergency fund
here in about three to four months
um
but i i guess i i've recently kind of
have a a little bit of a burden on my
shoulders and would like to like
alexa alexa you just dropped out the
last 10 seconds could you repeat that
speak directly into your phone
oh no there we go hello okay oh goodness
oh we missed some things so you kind of
said i would like to and we lost you're
going to be debt free and halfway funded
the emergency fund in three to four
months but you'd like to
just get some input or advice from you
as far as
lately i've had a little bit of a burden
um to kind of stay home with my kids
i've worked
their entire lives i have three
my oldest is seven so
i guess i just you know i feel like i've
missed a lot of them already
and i guess i would like to know
your input as to how to know financially
you know when
is a good time to stay home or if it's a
good time you know obviously getting out
of debt is
got to do my part so
yeah well i think you're financially
ready when you're financially ready to
make that move and so
i would want you to have a fully funded
emergency fund before we have this
conversation and then we need to figure
out can we live on your spouse's income
are we going to be okay can we cover all
the bills and still have the margin to
invest and save for the kids college and
pay off the house early and do all these
other things so he might need to get his
income up and ken can help in that
regard but i love the idea of you
staying home it just might be a not now
that's exactly right
the formula is really simple alexa you
can be a stay-at-home mom when you can
afford to
and so that's a combination of increased
income or lowering expenses
and you get to determine that that's
what's kind of fun about it but it's
also kind of frustrating right because
there's there's some patience there
and
it's just like anything else i'd say the
same thing to use i would say to
somebody who says ken i want to move
careers i want to change and i want to
pivot but it's going to take time to get
qualified you know it's going to get
take time to pay off debt to be able to
afford to be able to afford the
qualification process i get it
but it's going to be worth it
and if that's your big vision you better
put that front and center every day when
you wake up your mountaintop is
stay-at-home mom so in order to scale
that mountain what must be true what
must you do and you have the answers
george and i don't have the answers but
we can help and and i can tell you it's
increased income
and it is decreasing expenses what's his
take-home pay
his yes
uh about 55. yeah what yeah so
sorry that's that's gross that's gross
yeah so you know you and your husband
this is a steak dinner or whatever your
favorite dinner is
uh candlelight and let's dream together
and look at the budgets my dream is to
be a stay-at-home mom
is he on board if he is
what is his role what is your role this
is a team we lock arms and go this must
be true for me to come home and be
full-time with our babies yeah and
during logic do a fake budget as if
you're just living off of his income
i'll see how tight it is and see what
the gap is that's going to help you make
this a reality that's a great exercise
all right the reality is george
we still got more ramsay show more
breakthrough right around the corner
don't move
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me today
as we take your calls triple eight eight
two five five
two two five question of the day comes
from blinds.com blinds.com 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or pick the wrong color
they'll remake your blinds for free
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from spencer in ohio he
asks i currently attend community
college and want to pursue a bachelor's
degree in sportscasting this means i
will have to move out of state and
attend classes on campus most of my
community college costs were covered by
financial aid my worry is that if
financial aid and scholarships do not
cover the full cost of tuition and
housing when i change schools i will
have to take out student loans the
tuition amount for the degree is nearly
70 000
however with financial aid it may be
closer to forty thousand dollars i have
ten thousand saved up for my job what
are my options for paying off the rest
of this cost of this program well all
right george i'll let you take on that
one there but i'm gonna tell you right
now i uh
i started out in sports broadcasting i
do not have a degree in sports
broadcasting i have tons of friends that
are in sports broadcasting they don't
have a degree in sports broadcasting
this idea that a you have to have a
degree to be a sports broadcaster is
totally a myth number one number two why
in the world do you have to leave ohio
okay let's let me do we have two things
here uh
a you don't need the degree to be a
sports broadcaster but if you want to
get a sports broadcasting degree i don't
begrudge that if you can pay for it cash
and you don't go into debt but why would
you have to go out of state that's a
desire george not a requirement there's
plenty of state schools in ohio where as
a resident he's going to get a much
better discount and then that leads to
the question that he's asking uh on the
money piece he won't have as much debt
yeah well i see a lot of half dues well
that means i have to well that means i
have to take out student loans right and
that's where your language needs to
change you say i'm not taking out
student loans no matter what so where
does that leave me well right now it
leaves you with a 30 000 gap if you're
saying it's going to be closer to 40 i
have 10 saved so now i go okay if you
really want to pursue this and this is
the only path which it doesn't sound
like you've done your research to know
that then how quickly can i save up
thirty thousand dollars by working my
butt off in order to afford this but
before you even do that i go you don't
need to get a degree in sportscasting
you can get a degree in communication
you can get a degree in broadcasting you
can just go get some experience
somewhere like ken's talking about go
work your tail off for free at a radio
station and get some chops until you can
work your way into a position like that
and it may take seven eight years and
i'm okay with that
and if you can do it debt free that's
going to make this whole process a whole
lot easier and a whole lot less
stressful took me seven years to get to
ramsey solutions seven years from
starting from scratch no degree in
broadcasting at all i would also point
out that early on i took a sports
broadcasting school which was local in
atlanta and it cost a whopping 699
dollars and i learned stuff in that
little class
taught by a local sports producer that i
still use to this day what does that
tell you ken it's not about the piece of
paper it's about the person it's about
yeah it's about what do i need to learn
to do what i want to do and where are
all the places that i can do that
i love it so there it is good luck
spencer yeah i get it and people are
making these decisions right now in the
height of inflation and don't don't tell
me you have to don't put yourself in
some imaginary corner and back yourself
in and go i have to it's the only way
yeah i know all right george let's talk
inflation shall we yes so we took a call
earlier
uh about housing and it's a stressful
thing for a lot of people combating
inflation protecting your four walls and
so we've been doing a series on this
we've covered food and utilities we've
got those highlights on our youtube
channel for you to go check out and
today i want to talk about housing this
is a big issue whether you're renting or
you're looking to buy a house this is a
tough situation for a lot of people
we're seeing prices ballooning out of
control right now i mean we're seeing
some stats here rent is balloon 20 since
january 2021 we're seeing them be much
higher elsewhere 50 percent even 60 in
some areas with rent so let's talk about
ways to save on rent number one this is
uncomfortable no one wants to do it get
a roommate
i know you don't want to live with other
people people are complicated you want
to have your own space you don't want to
deal with the dishes sitting in the sink
but that person can cut your housing
expenses in half
and this can be a great temporary short
gap to get you to where you want to be
financially number two sign a longer
lease a lot of the times if you sign a
longer lease if you know you're going to
stay in the same place for a while you
can sign a 16-month lease an 18-month
lease and save some money that way and
lastly this is a crazy one
you can move out you can go find cheaper
rent elsewhere and it may mean moving
out of the fancy city and you're a
little further out
but if you can stomach the commute or if
you're a remote man that opens you up to
a lot of options when it comes to rent
do that now when it comes to buying a
house this is a big one ken people are
making some really terrible decisions
out there because of the fomo and the
market and they feel like if they don't
get in now they'll never get in now what
is the fomo george the fomo is the
housing prices are going up so fast that
i'll never be able to save up so why not
just do it now
even though i can't afford the mortgage
i'm just going to go ahead and do it and
worry about it later and i can tell you
we take plenty of calls here on the
ramsay show of people who call in and
say ken george i made a huge mistake we
jumped into a house too soon because we
were impulsive we skipped the appraisal
we skipped the inspection it's got the
roof is caving in which needs 20k of
work
and we don't know what to do and the
mortgage payment is we can't breathe
with this payment so i want you to buy a
house the right way and that means
saving money because you're not going to
be drowning so here's how to save on
housing number one save up 10 to 20
percent for your down payment and i want
you to avoid pmi that's private mortgage
insurance if you can put 20 down or more
which is money that protects the banks
not you
in case you can't pay
number two i want your your payment to
be no more than 25
of your monthly take-home pay on a
15-year fixed uh loan now that's hard
for a lot of people they go well come on
ken it's going to take me seven years to
get there i'm fine with that if it means
you're not broke for the next seven
years because you had no patience to
wait yeah and third this goes right into
this wait until the market cools down
we're seeing interest rates start to go
up which hopefully helps cool off the
market i'm not going to predict anything
but that's the hope so let's chill out
let's be patient let's take this time to
save up even more for the down payment
so that when it cools down we can make a
level-headed decision i got a thought
george you were talking about fomo and
uh fear of missing out is what you're
talking about i think it needs to be
foso fear of stressed out oh i like that
that's not good at all well that's not
good i want you all to check out the
full blog at ramseysolutions.com it's
called how to combat inflation and
protect your four walls we cover
everything from food utilities housing
transportation i think even if you do a
few of these ideas it will help create
some margin in your budget so that you
can breathe so that we can get through
this crazy time of influence very nice
all right back to the phones eric joins
us in the big apple new york city eric
how can we help
yeah so my question is um is it worth it
to spend uh 200 000
i highly doubt
to do an mba
i highly doubt it why do you think you
need the mba
i don't think i need it um i think it
has some real estate classes and uh i'm
interested in
um in real estate
but uh i'm already doing it i'm already
doing it and i'm not sure if the classes
are so why would an mba help you become
a better real estate agent why not just
sell a bunch of houses and get a bunch
of experience and be great with your
people skills
yeah i mean i'm not a real estate agent
i'm just investing on the side um
okay so
my question is yeah and i'm not sure if
that's helpful and the other thing is i
have a full-time job but i don't think i
need mba for a promotion or anything you
don't um that's what i was trying to
tell you
because i said i said the mba has
eric eric listen to me i said why do you
think you need it you went well i don't
think i need it i'm already doing it so
stop doing it
because my guess is you're not paying
cash for it are you paying cash for it
are you taking out loans
i probably won't take a long um i don't
have enough cash for that now but uh you
know it's a part-time program and over
time i'll i'll how are you doing your
real estate investing
yeah i have a mortgages and uh i also
have uh uh i also invest uh invest with
cash okay some kind of property
so we don't believe in debt
all right and you're in debt
on this real estate game
and you need all the cash that you can
to pay that debt off to get out of debt
which means no more cash going towards
an mba that you do not need nobody cares
if you have an mba
it'll never hold you back ever it'll
absolutely never hold you back
so don't take it george i mean he needs
that cash yeah to get out of debt stop
playing around with debt man this is
monopoly money it's going to screw you
over long term this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman george campbell joins me
our scripture of the day comes from
psalm 119 verse 66 teach me knowledge
and good judgment for i trust your
commands
our quote from
the billionaire founder of spanx a
lovely lady i had the opportunity to
interview at an entree leadership summit
that's right great not too long ago
sarah blakely it's important to be
willing to make mistakes the worst thing
that can happen is you become memorable
i like that i've also heard it said
george that
the worst mistake we make in life is
being afraid of making mistakes ooh
that's your meta huh that's so meta what
does that mean meta yeah it's just
within itself you know like the matrix
oh it's like the new spider-man with all
three spider-man just like that just is
am i wrong all the different universes
yeah meta you're teaching me folks he's
teaching me right here on the show joe
is up in kansas city joe how can we help
hey fellas how are you guys oh we're
having a blast joe what can we help you
with
well i got a question i i know when i
turned the show in a little while ago
you were talking about like job advice
and then it became you know switching
jobs things like that i love my job so
i'm in a sales organization we're at car
business okay uh so
we have all salesmen in one big room
uh i will be 55 this summer and one of
the issues i deal with is
i'm dad and
so like when i try to
you know lay some knowledge on the other
guys because i have been the number one
salesman several months uh some in a row
uh
okay dad uh
you you know basically advice and i kind
of get stickered off but
uh
the work ethic of half my age co-workers
how do i not let it get to me so they're
being disrespectful
no not disrespectful
but i just i i don't see
you know i will sell a couple dozen cars
a month uh that's just the way i work
and some months you know 40 some months
18 or 20 whatever
and they are happy with
uh six to eight yeah and i know i can't
i can't pay my bills on six months right
i'm not but let me ask you this joe
joe do when they when they sell way less
than you and they're happy about it does
that affect your paycheck at all
it does not and i realize that part of
it i you know i realize that we're not a
salary position and they can come and go
as they please
but
i just i see a lot of the guys there's a
couple particular that
man they could be doing so much better
yeah and guess what joe they're not get
joe first of all can i just tell you i
have tremendous empathy for you
i really i really do i'm 47 i'll be 48
in july we're not that far apart in age
i get
i get irritated all the time
by stuff like that with young people not
seeing what they need to see in the
moment doing what they need to do in the
moment but the reality is
we were like that once on some level
maybe not as bad but you're letting it
bother you so much and you started off
the phone call by saying
i love my job i like what i do
uh but i'm dad and i think that that dad
is coming that that the way you speak to
these guys and gals
is coming from a good place i think you
are trying to be that older wiser
gentleman to help them and i think your
heart is in the right place but your
attitude's not and it's coming across
that way and that's why they're calling
you dead and instead of getting
you know
bent out of shape about it
you need to listen to that and go it's
probably not cool that they're saying
that to you but you're also coming
across in a way that they're kind of
calling out in their own way and so you
don't need to be dad
because see dad
see i say whatever i want to when i want
to to my three kids they don't have to
like it they live in my house
they are the beneficiaries of my hard
work joe
but
these guys and gals aren't your kids
they don't live in your house so
you don't need to give them advice
unless they ask for it
and here's one okay and i know it's hard
to hear joe but listen here's why
i know but listen
they don't want your advice
and until they want your advice
don't give it
because even though they need your
advice
when you give it and they don't want it
it's not received and then it hacks you
off even more
go in and do your job
do the best that you can do
model the way
and and stay to yourself
and shake your head when they're not
around
comment on this younger generation all
you want to
stop giving them advice
because here's the deal i appreciate it
here's the deal that's going to lower
your blood pressure and it's going to
make your job so much more enjoyable
it's not your problem
even though you can help it's not your
problem george you are a millennial yeah
anything i said wrong there uh i'm not
jealous i felt it i'm going man this
resentment is only on joe they're not
affected by it they're brushing you off
and so you focus on selling cars and let
them focus on selling cars and one day
they're going to go how does joe sell so
many cars that's right that guy's got
financial margin in his life i want that
right now they're young probably single
they're just blowing their money on the
weekends yeah and that's just part of a
misled youth they'll get there they'll
come around yeah and by the way they'll
see and and they've heard what you've
said they've just chosen not to listen
it's not illegal to not work hard this
is america yeah i get it joe
move on you know do your thing dalen is
in salt lake city utah dalen how can we
help
hey thanks for taking my call you bet
okay so i have a quick question um i'm
getting promoted at work um
and that promotion is out of state so
i'm thinking
you know i have some debt right now um
obviously i was newly married you know
with my wife i was of last november
and uh
together
uh we have about four thousand dollars
in credit card debt
and um i'm thinking it'll be wise and
i'm just getting a second opinion i'm
thinking it'll be wise
to attack that four thousand dollars of
credit card debt then shock up for the
move and then move from like august you
know just in time for my promotion do
you think that's a good idea
yeah i didn't know the urgency of having
to move but if you can control the
timeline at all absolutely i want you to
be able to get out of debt and stack up
for the move pay everything in cash and
i want you to have an emergency fund as
well but if we can do that as soon as we
move that's our next goal i'm okay with
that and you're going to live on even
less than you're living on now even with
your raise and that's going to help you
get there even faster
that's that's my wife and i's mindset
right there so i'm just getting a second
city now if you had to move next month
i'm going to say hey let's pause it at
snowball we're kind of in a storm right
now we've got to stack up cash to pay
for the move
uh but if you control the timeline
absolutely let's get rid of this credit
card debt and then cut up the cards and
never go into debt again
no are you getting any type of uh you
getting any type of money for the move
from the new company
i'm not getting any money for the move
itself but i am getting about a three to
four thousand dollar race
a month okay gotcha a month that's great
congratulations by the way on the new
promotion very exciting and uh love the
call i love the forward thing on this
because do you have this is your lane
i'm putting you on the spot uh do you
know what an average move costs these
days you know i've seen some packages
out there with salaries sometimes
they'll throw five ten thousand dollars
to help with the move situation yeah it
depends on your life yeah obviously if
you're moving
west coast obviously that's more
expensive yeah i'm just curious that
there was an average
cost of moving because i tell you what
it's i imagine the prices are going up
on that just like they are gas
especially anything else yeah you're
trying to get a truck across the country
it ain't cheap no
but you know i've seen it's definitely
going to be a few thousand dollars it
can be upward of 10 anything beyond that
would make my stomach hurt you're
spending more than that to move
moving's the worst even just moving
around town you know you're gonna spend
a thousand two thousand dollars on some
good movers and let me tell you i'm not
asking my friends i'm big on that higher
movers yeah i think everybody pretty
much agrees with that it's the quickest
way to destroy friendships i would
rather donate twenty dollars to your
gofundme let me play devil's house
but i'm gonna offer them beer and pizza
george i mean no
i don't want that for back-breaking work
and your buddy's out of shape already
yeah and you're having to move this
furniture as he dents it up true story
dangerous true story back in the day
me uh me and about five or six buddies
we were asked by a friend to help him
move so what do you do you have to say
yes so we showed up one of my clown
buddies james was wearing a weight belt
as if that was going to support his back
you know the belt you see a lot of these
movers wear the velcro deal he shows up
with an old-fashioned leather way i love
that as if that was going to help his
poor back that's a good friend by the
way the weight belt came off within 30
minutes of starting the move all right
good stuff george campbell thanks for
being with me thanks to james captain of
the ship and everybody in the control
room thank you america this is your show
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you